bonjour c'est cyprien vous allez bien
moi ça va pas trop j'ai fait mon premier
bid 1 mais un bon beat quoi imaginer
imaginons ça c'est un bide normal là
j'ai fait pour s'en rendre compte il
suffit de regarder le nombre d'avis
négatifs sur youtube
alors au début j'étais bon et après
quelques instants de réflexion respire
voilà bon gros jeu vidéo c'est un clip
humoristique sur un mec qui s'habille
mal et à la fin il s'habille tellement
mal qu'il s'habille bien c'est pas super
clair en plus j'avoue bon la vidéo
s'appelle comme une merde comme une
merde
le titre lui va bien alors c'est un
monsieur j'ai tenu bon pour synthétiser
l'avis général s'il fallait matérialiser
cette vidéo ce serait un cas car je me
lave les mains
maintenant il ya plein de raisons
d'expliquer ce fait il a l'humour était
trop éloigné de ce que je fais
d'habitude c'était trop méchant le sujet
était maltraitée et je commence à
comprendre que les musiques c'est pas
trop mon truc à la prochaine fois que je
fais une chanson c'est simple et j'ai
une idée de chanson péter mois les
genoux merci mec
d'ailleurs la vidéo est toujours en
ligne elle est juste plus répertoriés
sur ma chaîne parce que c'est devenu un
petit peu un lieu de violence et d'
insulte un un petit peu comme dans le
film 300 en fait
à peu de choses près donc si vous aimez
vous faire du mal vous pouvez toujours
voir la vidéo
le lien est dans la description sur
youtube d'ailleurs vous pouvez y mettre
un pouce rouge parce que c'est dommage
et encore un petit peu de vert dans la
barre alors je sais qu'il ya un forum et
la communauté qui va avec qui s'amusent
à amplifier cette vague d'avis négatifs
et de commentaires insultants
c'est de la merde connard va te pendre
cool et je n'ai absolument rien contre
ça les gens peuvent noter et commenter
ce qu'ils veulent d'ailleurs si ma vidéo
était réussie je n'aurais pas eu tous
ces commentaires bref je me suis planté
tu t'es planté comme une merde c'était
le chien jouait devant maintenant que
j'ai retenu les leçons je bossais sur
d'autres vidéos en espérant qu'elle nous
décevront plus personne à dieu